you are a superorganism while that
sounds incredibly awesome and science
fiction what it actually means is
possibly even cooler you are a single
organism that is made up of billions of
other organisms and of course those
organisms are bacteria your microbiome
these are not all bad in fact a huge
number of the 500 to 1,000 different
species found in the human body
are incredibly important for our health
performance and even brain function it's
well known fact at this point that the
human body contains more bacterial cells
than human cells and the same goes for
your DNA you contain roughly 100
trillion bacteria which is a lot you are
more bacteria than human this is what
we're referring to and we discussed the
microbiome or the microbiota which has a
slightly narrower definition and those
bacteria aren't just freeloaders they
play crucial symbiotic roles in the body
which are so important as to be a key
part of who we are in fact our own cells
are made partly from ancient bacteria in
a sense our mitochondria the energy
factories of our body are actually
evolved from an ancient alpha
proteobacteria more than 3.5 billion
years ago this explains why our
mitochondria contain entirely different
sets of DNA as compared with the rest of
our cells what's more exciting from a
performance point of view is that the
microbiota of the gut specifically has a
huge impact on your mood your metabolism
your cardiovascular performance and
intelligence and more this has led to
the gut sometimes being referred to as
the second brain the potential impact of
the microbiome on weight loss is also
particularly potent in one case study a
woman received a fecal transplant which
is a transplant of fecal matter from one
person to another from her overweight
relative to treat a serious health
condition while the transplant was a
success and the illness was halted in
its tracks
she soon began to notice that her body
was different than now healthy recipient
of the foreign faeces and thus foreign
bacteria began to gain weight and
nothing she could do would help her to
control it more exciting still as the
bacteria could directly influence muscle
mass formation in one study researchers
transplanted the gut bacteria from wild
mice into mice that had been raised to
entirely lack a gut mic
Beata which led to a marked increase in
muscle mass and a reduction in muscular
atrophy in fact a person's microbiome
which is far more unique from one person
to another than their DNA can
potentially be used as one of the best
indicators of body composition and even
athletic performance if you're
struggling to lose weight then build
muscle or focus it might be because your
microbiome is negatively affecting your
metabolism meanwhile a whole field of
psycho biotics is concerned with
exploring the use of beneficial bacteria
in improving mood and focus essentially
this is using probiotics as nootropics -
how do bacteria do all this well they're
able to affect many processes in the
body through a range of different
methods firstly they produce digestive
enzymes to help break down foods and aid
to digestion
this helps with the absorption of
nutrients and therefore supports overall
health they produce neurotransmitters
which affect the network of neurons
lining the gut and impact on our mood
our focus and more they boost the immune
system by fighting bad bacteria in the
gut and they're even able to talk to the
mitochondria via cellular signaling
owing to that shared common ancestry
this can improve energy production as
bacteria produce short chain fatty acids
SFC a s called butyrate that can be
burned by the mitochondria to create ATP
providing more energy butyrate also
affects gene expression muscle and brown
fat and encourages fatty oxidation via
ampk what is all very interesting but
it's not terribly actionable what can we
do to improve our gut microbiome and
thus our body composition brain function
and athletic performance in the book
Peak dr. mark burbs collects a huge
amount of relevant data on this point as
well as useful tips and advice in the
article linked in the description of
this video I'll list a bunch of
bacterial strains that have been studied
for their effects on brain and body I
list them all there and I explain what
each appears to do for either brain or
body check that out if you want to
create your own microbiome diet this
information has been collected by
looking at the guts of hunter-gatherer
tribes in Tanzania as well as the guts
of high-performance athletes other
studies involve introducing microbes
drains into the diets of participants
via probiotics and other means to see
what effect they have on mood
performance or weight gain from all this
we can begin to paint a picture of what
a healthy
it might look like with regards to
supporting gut health it should be high
fiber and contain fermented foods dairy
and starch athletes with healthy
microbiomes ate large quantities of
vegetables fruits and nuts and steered
more towards whole-grain breads dirt can
even improve your microbiome so don't
wash those organic vegetables too
thoroughly
another obvious option is to try and use
probiotic products to enhance your gut
health
these are yogurts tablets and drinks
that contain large amounts of bacterial
cultures so do they work do they
actually do it they promise well the
good news is that some studies do seem
to show an effect these are currently
quite limited in scope and number right
now however and most conclude that it's
too early to draw concrete conclusions
when choosing a probiotic if you do
choose to go that route or a supplement
you should focus on the CFM you count
CFU stands for colony forming unit which
tells you just how many live and active
microorganisms are found in a serving
most products range between 5 to 30
billion CFU so aim for 30 if possible
generally more is better but you also
need to read which strains are actually
in the product and whether these have
been shown to do anything useful try to
avoid simple sugars a cellular carbs and
highly processed foods which provide a
ready source of fuel for the
inflammation promoting bad bacteria but
dr. Bub's warns against falling into the
trap of a reductionist approach you
can't control your bacteria precisely
enough to try and raise specific
quantities of microbes and each of us
has such a unique microbiome that the
same approach isn't going to work for
everyone a better strategy is to be
generally healthy and to listen to your
own body indeed by far the most
important property of a healthy gut
biome according to all the research is
diversity the greater the range of
bacteria the more balanced it will be
try to think of this like maintaining an
organic garden the best way to get rid
of aphids is not to spray them with a
chemical insecticide but rather to
attract a lady birds to your garden and
build a stronger ecosystem the same is
true of your gut and by having a broad
range of bacteria in there you'll be
healthier you'll achieve a better
balance it's a curious thought that
actually isn't in the best interest of
any bacteria to kill its host some have
suggested that this is proof that those
strains of bacteria are in the early
stages of evolution or that their
negative effects are more the result of
imbalance
either way it seems that no bacteria is
truly evil and this is where our modern
lifestyles can actually be beneficial
head to your local supermarket and stock
up on natural whole food there's been
imported from as many different
countries as possible you can also try
following the 50 food challenge which
involves trying to conceive 50 different
foods in seven days each week
dr. Bub's recommends that if you suffer
from low energy bloating poor mood or
uncontrolled weight gain that you first
try using a restrictive diet in order to
cut back the bacteria that's already
there so that actually means reducing
fiber intake and eating only very simple
and bland foods for a while while also
seeking out antimicrobial foods and
supplements such as garlic
this helps to trim back the overgrowth
allowing you to effectively start over
once your symptoms have settled down you
can then begin to build your gut flora
back up by introducing those more varied
and complex ingredients many factors
outside of your diet also affect the gut
health good sleep is also key to a
healthy gut perhaps surprisingly your
microbiome also has a sleep-wake cycle
just like you so if you don't sleep you
can actually cause damage to your
friendly micro allies just as the
microbiome is able to aid the
performance of your mitochondria it also
transpires that the reverse is true
optimally functioning microc Andreea
also helps support a healthy microbiome
thus fitness training and especially
high intensity interval training could
help to boost your microbiome
overtraining however can be extremely
bad for your gut health as can any form
of stress gut brain axis is an important
area of study looking at the interaction
between the gut health and stress our
microbiota communicates with our brain
via the vagus nerve as well as via the
immune system tryptophan metabolism SC
FAS
gut hormone signaling and more pathways
this interaction is a kind of two-way
street and if you experience a lot of
chronic stress that can take a serious
toll on your gut only use antibiotics as
a last resort as they take a
scorched-earth approach to the fight
against bad bacteria and completely
eliminate your healthy gut flora it may
take over a year for this to grow back
if you do need antibiotics then make
sure to spend time rebuilding and
monitoring your gut health immediately
afterwards so don't go crazy and spend
too much time worrying about all this
but just being aware of it can help to
make healthier choices and to feel
better as a result that's basically how
you support a healthy microbiome to
improve
your health wellness energy focus muscle
mass weight loss and more let me know
down below if this is something you
already do or if you plan to reconsider
your diet in light of this information I
hope you found this video useful and
interesting if you did then please leave
a like and share it around that helps me
out immensely likewise subscribe to the
channel if you want more like this and
don't forget to check out the article
over at the bio near calm before you
guys go I just want to let you know that
I'm finally working on a book that takes
all of the information from the bio near
the channel and the website and combines
it into a single tome a huge
comprehensive guide to the brain and
body and the unique and interesting ways
you can train it hack it and get the
most out of it lots of people who
comment on this channel say that they
like all the information but they don't
know how to combine it all into one
actionable plan so that's exactly what
this book is going to do whilst also
exposing a ton of other fascinating
areas of research that I haven't had
time yet to cover here the books called
super functional training it's going to
be a really big and well presented PDF
with lots of images lots of flow charts
and diagrams which will not only outline
and explain the training you need to do
to optimize your body and mind in a
single program but also hopefully
motivate you and get you really
fascinated and excited to get the most
out of your body if that all sounds
interesting you can actually preorder
that right now following the link in the
description down below and if you do
then you'll get $10 off the final price
it's going to be $35 on release which
might change I don't know it's going to
be $25 right now if you preorder there
and you'll also gain access to some
exclusive content if you do that thanks
a ton to everyone who's already ordered
their copy and yeah I'll share more
information about it as we go on this
channel I'm really excited for own it
releases on November the 4th this year a
ton for watching guys and stay tuned for
the next one I'll see you then bye for
now